- [Mark] All right, Alex.
- Sir.
- [Mark] Alex, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Alex] Born and raised in Pico Rivera.
- [Mark] Pico Rivera.
- [Alex] Yeah.
- [Mark] Suburb of LA.
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were growing up?
- No, growing up, it was my mother
and my grandmother, my great-grandmother.
Dad is in prison, you know?
No type of father figures,
just women, raised by women.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- It was all right.
I don't have too many bad memories of it.
But now that I'm older
and look back at it,
it lacked a lot of affection.
- [Mark] And you joined
the gang at what age?
- About 14, I became a full-blown member.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And you've done prison
time, I assume, right?
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] When did that start for you?
- Well, I started doing juvenile hall
at 13, 14 years old, you know what I mean?
And you know, when I was 17,
I was around my older homeboys.
Older than me, dudes were like
25, 26 years old, you know?
And I started doing armed
robberies with them.
And we started doing real heavier crimes,
I was doing heavier
crimes with older dudes.
So I was imprisoned at 18.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So that means YA, at that point?
- No, state prison.
- Oh, prison?
- Yeah, state prison.
At 17 years, eight
months, they convicted me.
- [Mark] And what was that for?
- Laying in wait, attempted murder.
- [Mark] Attempted murder, it's the same--
- And laying in wait.
Parked in front of his house,
waiting for anybody to come
in and out of the house
to jump out and get him.
- [Mark] Okay.
So how many years did you do?
- I did 16 years, eight months.
- [Mark] 16 years.
So, I mean, prison,
you were in and out, I assume?
- I did my 16 years straight.
Got out, stood out for a good three years.
It's easier if you stood out.
And then I started fucking around
in my neighborhood again,
started hanging out with
my neighborhood gang
and started just, you know.
I started violating and just
spiraled back down again.
Now I'm back running
around the streets again.
- [Mark] You've been
out for how many years?
- Since 2014.
- [Mark] And did that
lifestyle affect your,
like, do you have family?
Do you have kids, do you have a wife?
- Well, I didn't have my family
until after I got out of prison.
But yeah, now it's affecting it.
It has affected my relationship
with my wife and my kids right here.
- [Mark] Yeah, did you raise your kids?
Were you there for them?
- All through the pregnancies,
for my son and my daughter,
I was at the whole pregnancies.
I was there till my daughter was four
and my son was three.
Well, going on three,
that's when we broke up.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And looking back at your life,
do you have regrets of this?
- Oh yeah, I have regrets, but same time,
I'm like, "Fuck it, I did
it, I chose this lifestyle."
You know what I mean?
So I'm doing it, what more
can I say other than that?
- [Mark] You're still doing it?
- I run around still, yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So did drugs come into the picture
for you at some point?
- In prison, you know.
Prior to prison, I wasn't
too heavy into drugs.
But in prison, I didn't have much to do,
you know what I mean?
You're sitting in a cell.
I did all my time with a little 401 80.
You know what I mean,
they've gotta be lasting
or you're slammed down.
It's one of the only things to do,
one of the escapes, I guess you'd say.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And was there heroin?
- Heroin.
- [Mark] Yeah, that seems to
be the go-to drug for the--
- Well, it knocks you out,
puts you out for the day.
Kills the whole day, kills time, you know?
- [Mark] So what kind
of stories can you tell?
- Aw man, I don't know, man.
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] I'm sure you got
more than a few.
(Alex laughs)
- Like, foul ones, there are
some that are just like...
It depends what you--
- [Mark] Give me the most
horrifying story you got.
You can be vague about some
details if you need to.
To protect the guilty.
- Yeah.
All right.
2000, I was a porter.
You know, a janitor in the buildings.
And we were waiting for somebody
to come back from a visit.
And he's bringing in dope, you know,
everybody's waiting for him to get back.
Well, my door stays cracked open
'cause I go in and out, I'm a porter.
So when the dude comes
back from the visit,
I go straight over there and I'm like,
"'Ey, come on."
And he's like, "Well hold
on, let me do my thing first.
"Come back in a half hour or so."
And I was like, man.
I come back in a half hour and he's dead.
He's OD'ed, you know what I mean?
And I'm like damn, I
don't know what to do.
So I go call someone who's waiting
for another guy, right?
I say "Hey man, come here.
"What do we do?"
And he was like, "Fuck, how
long has he been like this?"
I said, "I don't know, he told me
"to come back in a half hour
and I came back in a half hour
"and this is how I found him."
And he said, "Well, where's the dope at?"
I said, "I don't know
where the dope's at."
And he was like, "What do
you mean you don't know?"
I go like, "I don't know
where the fucking dope's at.
"I don't know, he didn't have no dope."
So we looked around real quick for dope,
we couldn't find none.
So this dude, older dude, about 50,
snaps his fingers and goes,
"Fuck, it's still inside him."
And I was like, "All right, well, okay."
He was like, "Get some gloves."
And I was like "Get some gloves?"
He's like "Yeah, get some gloves."
So first you get gloves,
and then he's like,
"Go bring some razors."
I'm like, "What do you do?"
He's like, "We gotta get
that out of his ass."
And I was like, "What do you
mean get it out of his ass?"
He was like, "We're gonna cut his ass open
"and I'm gonna put a fucking glove on,
"and I'ma get the dope out of his ass."
So that's what we did.
And that was pretty fucking foul.
It was an experience, I mean.
It's for dope.
It's just to get that stupid dope.
We got in trouble behind it
at the end of the day, anyway.
You know?
That was my bad memories
in prison, you know?
It wasn't good, it--
- [Mark] That was in prison?
- That was in prison, yeah.
And that's--
- [Mark] Is the gang life in prison,
I know it's different,
but how is it different
than outside on the street?
- Your homeboys on the streets,
you're not only homeboys, you're friends.
A lot of them, you went
to school with them,
you have friendships with them,
you know their families
and things like this.
So there's a lot more leniency
amongst each other, you know?
But in prison, there's no leniency.
When you get there, they
give you the verbal,
here's your verbal, the
rules and regulations.
And they give you something to read
that has all the rules.
And those are your two warning shots,
anything after this, no more,
we're not talking to you.
Right now it's just, we're gonna do you.
Back at that time when I was in prison,
there was that race riot.
There were racial issues, you know?
Right now, it's not so bad
with the racial issues back to how it was
in Calapat, in Ironwood, places like that.
You only had one opportunity to mess up,
you messed up, you're out of here.
We can't afford to have
no fuck-ups, none of that.
Everybody has to be
ready to go at all times.
Everybody has to be thinking all the time.
You can't be like, "Oh, I just woke up
"and I wasn't thinking."
There's none of that, you know?
So less lenient, you know what I mean?
- [Mark] Yeah.
Were you around for the drive-by era,
or not really?
- Yeah.
Heavily, yeah.
- [Mark] So drive-bys were
for what purpose, just--
- [Alex] Just to shoot somebody.
Shoot someone, you know?
Back then in the drive-by zone,
I don't know if it was because
there were more guns
in the streets or what.
I don't know the reason why.
But back then, everybody shot back.
Now you can shoot at
somebody and half the time,
they don't even really shoot back at you.
But back in the drive-by times,
when you came by and you shot at somebody,
it's 'cause everybody would
shoot right back at you,
you know what I mean?
Most of the time.
So it wasn't like you're
just driving guns.
Like, driving in front of the center,
you're just stopping
and shooting somebody.
You expected for them to shoot back,
or like they might have homeboys
on the side of the street
or something, you know what I mean?
It was a lot more gunplay.
When I was growing up in the early '90s,
the late '80s, early '90s,
especially in the
Southeast, South Hollywood,
Beachwood and Whittier,
Norwalk and all that?
There was a lot of gang mines.
It was like all day, every day.
It wasn't like at the middle of the night.
It was like, "Let's go right
now when school gets out."
'Cause there's just trains,
airplanes, there's traffic,
no one's gonna hear the
gunshots two, three blocks away
like they would at night, you know?
So that was in my teens.
After school, we'd go over
to my enemy's neighborhood,
to the high schools in their neighborhood.
And they'd be hanging
out with their bitches,
we'd go over there, look for them,
and try to shoot them.
Plain and simple, you know?
- [Mark] As an outsider
looking at the gang world,
it just seems ridiculous to me
that there can be somebody
who lives in the town next to you
who's your enemy for no good reason
other than just he lives
across the tracks from you.
- Well, the thing is--
- And you could be friends with him today.
- You're right.
It doesn't make sense,
but if everything did make sense.
And other people don't
understand on the outside,
they say, "How can you
fight for the street
"or fight for these,"
You're not fighting for that,
they're fighting for a blood feud.
They already exist because maybe
while you were in junior high,
they killed your friend, fucking Michael,
who was from the gang.
Before you though, you know, maybe.
So now you've already lost friends
to this blood feud that's going on.
And it's not even about
this or that anyone,
it's about they're killing us,
we gotta go kill them now.
That's what's happening, you know?
- [Mark] It's almost like
human nature on some level.
- Yeah, gangs are like tribes.
It's like tribal warfare,
you know what I mean?
Pretty much, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
And your kids are following
in your dad's footsteps, or no?
- No, hell no.
Not at all.
My babies' mama, she was born
and raised in Catalina Island.
They're white people,
you know what I mean?
I don't mean that disrespectfully,
but they're square people,
you know what I mean?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- They worked all their life.
They're not being raised in
a bad environment at all.
- [Mark] What do they think of their dad?
- They love me, my kids love me.
They don't see nothing other but me.
They just know me, getting
up and getting them bottles,
getting up and watching PBS with them,
or getting up and putting
a movie on for them.
That's all they know.
- [Mark] But you have a
good relationship with them?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] With your kids?
- Yeah, yeah.
Her name is Grace, since
me and Grace have broke up,
she uses them a little more
as sort of tools to her a little more.
'Cause I could care
less about her no more,
but sometimes she likes to use the kids
as a way to, you know...
Well, what can you do, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
How has the gang experienced
change since you were young?
- Oh, it's weak now.
It's not the same no more.
I remember when I was younger,
the older guys used to say that about us.
And now I know it's not just
something that's being said,
'cause you look back and you're like,
"Man, back then we would've done this,
"or we would've done that."
Or "Back then, those guys couldn't have
"come into our neighborhood
"right on the wall back then."
It's things like that, you know?
You knew the difference, you know?
- [Mark] There was more loyalty?
- A lot more loyalty.
And you know, it's funny,
I tell this to people, like
people don't understand it.
But I blame the attitude
on fucking rap music,
like Black music, those that are like,
"Fuck everybody, I'm just trying
"to get money for myself."
And they're all individualists.
Coming into a gang and
being all by yourself,
that's not game mentality,
you know what I mean?
That game mentality's lacking now,
like one for everybody.
Everybody's kind of like,
"Why join a group if you wanna be alone?"
So lacks a lot of loyalty.
- [Mark] What's the most important lesson
you've learned in life?
- Don't tell nobody what you're doing.
Ever.
Or where you're going, just don't.
You just don't tell
nobody nothing, you know?
Pretty much.
That's the best way to say it, yeah.
- [Mark] Where do you see
your life going from here?
How old are you?
- I'm 43.
- [Mark] 43?
Still young.
- Yeah.
It's hard, man.
Because I've been doing
jail or prison all my life.
And my dad it, and my grandpa did it.
I mean, my dad is still
in prison right now.
He's 67 years old, he's still in prison.
And my uncle's sort of like that.
I look at them, I'm like,
"Fuck, man, I don't
want to be 55 years old,
"still going and doing violations."
I'm 43 and I keep doin' 'em,
why are you going there?
Now I'm already like,
"I can't do this shit."
These people around me get nervous.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Mark] But with your record,
it's going to be hard to
get a square job, right?
- Yeah, it's hard.
But I don't even worry
about trying to have a job.
Honestly, I don't worry about that
because I'm trying to get money
however I can and wherever I can.
And unfortunately, that's the
situation I put myself in.
So I accept it for what it is, you know?
At the same time, though,
if I were to put my habits aside,
and I go to a job agency,
they'll give me a fucking job
and I can go work, you know what I mean?
It's not impossible for me to get a job.
To me, that's making excuses, lying,
for not really wanting to work.
'Cause you can get a job.
- [Mark] You think the gang direction
for young men is more a
product of environment
or the family, or the friends he had?
What do you think got you into the gang?
Or gets young men to follow that path?
'Cause if you grow up in
Santa Barbara or something,
you probably wouldn't--
- Yeah, and you got gang members
coming out of Santa Barbara.
I don't understand that.
I think it's the environment a little bit,
but at the same time, it's also...
A lack of belonging somewhere.
Life is social, you gotta be
put in some type of group,
you gotta be accepted
by whoever you're gonna be accepted by.
Because everybody wants to be accepted
by somebody or whatever.
- [Mark] That becomes your family?
- Yeah, you know what I mean?
And maybe gangs, they look good to people.
Basically, it looks good,
you get girls or whatever the fuck,
you're doing this, you're doing that.
But you don't see the other side
before you join a gang
that you're going to prison.
You're from a gang,
you're going to prison.
And now there's people,
there's gang members
who are like hoping to dodge prison.
It's like, that's part of the lifestyle.
Prison's gonna happen,
you know what I mean?
Just for how long is the question.
But if you're a gang member,
you're going to prison.
Otherwise you're not being a gang member.
I don't know what you're doing,
but you're not being a gang member.
- [Mark] What advice would you give
to a young man who's
considering doing this?
Today?
(Alex sighs)
- I'm not gonna say it's
not worth it nowadays,
'cause everybody's worth it.
To other people, even to me.
I have no regrets about it.
But I would just say,
"Make sure it's really what you wanna do."
'Cause you gotta carry that
around with you forever,
you know what I mean?
And some people aren't
capable of the violence,
they think they are.
And so they do it,
and then they gotta keep to themselves.
I've seen some people not be
able to handle the violence,
and they do.
Everybody thinks they can
do this, they can do that,
but when they actually have
to get up there and do it,
and you do it, how are
you gonna feel afterwards?
- [Mark] And you live with it
for the rest of your life.
- Yeah, are you gonna be able
to sleep with yourself
after that, you know?
So it's like, make sure
you're really ready to do,
ready to take that step, you know?
And to be able to control it.
Once you do take that step,
now it's a question of like,
having to decide when to do that.
Now it's not an issue like
being boastful or prideful when I say,
I already know I could do that.
But can I do it and get away with it?
And if I do do it, what's
gonna happen afterwards?
You know, now it's a question of that.
It's not about...
- [Mark] Pulling the trigger.
- Yeah, it's not just
pulling the trigger no more.
Now there's other things you
gotta contemplate, you know?
- [Mark] All right, Alex.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with me.
And good luck with wherever
you go from here, man.
- Thank you very much, man.
- [Mark] Thanks, man.
That's great.